in three separate strikes
israel again showed what it can do at
will to gaza's skyline
the al-sharook tower contains shops
offices and homes
and on its top floor the
hamas-affiliated al-aqsa tv
occupants had been told by israel to
leave
seconds after the attack began the
building's silhouette
replaced by smoke and dust
across gaza a cloud of grief is
spreading
taking hold of families infecting a new
generation
[Music]
as the deaths mount so does the feeling
that this is just the beginning
my daughter-in-law and my grandson died
and my granddaughter is missing without
any trace
the jews target women and children my
son's wife was five months pregnant
this is terrorism
less than an hour after the al-sharukh
building was brought down
another rocket barrage began
again israel's iron dome interceptors
trying to deal with a huge number of
targets
hamas said it fired 130 rockets several
got through
to the town of sterot a six-year-old boy
killed
in one direct hit on a building
others exploding in the coastal town of
ashkelon
earlier israel killed six senior hamas
commanders
close to the head of the military wing
and involved in intelligence and rocket
production
a short while ago we eliminated top
commanders of the hamas general staff
including the gaza city brigade
commander and other commanders
and this is just the beginning we'll hit
them like they've never dreamed possible
but there is another growing crisis for
benjamin netanyahu and his government
away from this accelerating military
escalation
in and around gaza across israel from
town to town
there is an eruption of communal
violence
between jews and arabs despite
netanyahu's
own pledge to bring it to an end with an
iron fist
on tuesday night jewish cars and a
synagogue were torched
on wednesday it was a mosque that burned
[Applause]
elsewhere arab businesses were ransacked
jewish crowds chanted death to arabs
communities used to living close to each
other doing business with each other
driven by violence and hatred israel
facing a social and security crisis on
its streets
as it wages an escalating conflict with
gaza's fighting factions
harry fawcett al-jazeera southern israel
well robbie curry is the director of
global engagement at the american
university of beirut joins me now via
skype from boston in the us mr curry
always good to have you on the programme
um we've seen this huge surge really of
intercommunal violence which harry
mentioned in his report between jewish
and arab communities
across parts of israel that we would
never have heard of before
how much of a game changer is this now
i don't know if inter-communal violence
is the best way to describe it it's
predominantly
israelis private sector gangs
often protected by the police um
attacking
palestinians and then after a while the
palestinians start
fighting back so the pattern is that the
israeli government
and the the the gangs of young men
have been working for years and years to
try to judaize most of
palestine as much as they can they can't
judaize at all because there's
several million there's about five
million palestinians living
west of the jordan river and the
occupied territories and
israel proper but the the the plan
that the israelis the actions they've
always used have been to
slowly push out palestinians um like
using uh legal means
like military actions that destroy homes
and people
try to get people to flee either out of
fear or simply out of not being able to
live normally anymore
and then the third one is to incite the
local fear and violence among
small groups of people maybe one family
maybe a neighborhood
and and get the palestinians to go out
the striking thing about this is that
this has been the pattern
since around 1920. this is not
just last week or since 67 or since 48.
this is how the palestinian israeli
the zionist arabist conflict started
way back in the 1920s as small groups of
jews
organized and planned after the balfour
declaration
in 1917 planned to create a jewish
homeland
and a jewish state and to do that they
had to push out as many palestinians as
possible this has been documented by
israeli scholars international agencies
a lot of people so this is the context
in which we're seeing
this violence now the palestinians fight
back
in any way they can but they're way
outnumbered and outgunned
by the israeli government and the and
the private folks
so this is what you end up with so i
mean here and now then how do you think
the israeli
authorities are going to deal with these
clashes between arabs and israeli jews
i say west of the jordan river in places
uh
like haifa accra
these clashes these clashes very much
serve the interests of the ruling
right-wing majority including netanyahu
right now and in fact many of these
groups that
carry out these actions belong to
parties that are
among the right-wing militant coalitions
coalition group so the israeli
government will make noises about
protecting all the citizens but they
will just
let the violence continue and the
government itself
conducts much of the violence either
through military actions
or through the legal system so i
you i don't think you're going to see
any short-term
serious action by the israeli government
to to reign
rein in these gangs who go around
beating up arabs or killing them or
breaking into their
houses they want to continue this has
been the tool
of choice violence terrorizing
frightening tormenting
families and neighborhoods to gradually
increase the jewish population
and decrease the palestinian population
they'll stop it for a week or two
maybe with a talk on the white house uh
phone call
and then it'll it'll resume and it
resumes by legal means
and military means on political means
and
and private violence means so this is
the real
problem that the palestinians face they
have this
powerful israeli state supported at the
beginning of this process a century ago
by the united kingdom and france a
little bit now supported by the united
states so there's no way that the
palestinians
can fight back against this in any
serious way so the solution is a
political
resolution that's the only solution
really that we should aim for
we should see what does happen it's
always good to get your insight randy
curry thanks so much for joining us from
boston thank you